amy coney barrett taking the first of
two o's to become the next supreme court
justice
it happened outdoors at the white house
last night a month after barrett's
nomination announcement became a
coronavirus super spreader event we
remember that
this was a big political victory for the
president just over a week before
election day
mr trump heads to three states today
meanwhile the coronavirus pandemic
continues to worsen
with daily cases up in 43 states
wisha chang is at the white house which
is dealing with an outbreak among vice
president pence's staff
how did that affect last night's event
good morning anthony vice president
pence was not seen at the high profile
event and his office has not provided
any information
about why despite our multiple requests
president trump wanted the focus of the
night to be his supreme court pick
but the impact of covet 19 was
impossible
to ignore she will make an outstanding
justice
president trump wasted no time calling a
crowd to the white house to witness the
swearing-in of judge amy coney barrett
his third supreme court appointee i will
do my job
without any fear or favor and that i
will do so
independently is there a sufficient
second
less than two hours earlier the
republican-controlled senate confirmed
48-year-old barrett
in one of the most partisan supreme
court processes
ever no democrats voted in her favor
the nomination of amy coney barrett of
indiana to be an associate justice of
the supreme court of the united states
is confirmed
the president hopes securing barrett
will help him at the polls
since she provides conservatives a 6-3
majority
in a matter of months the justices will
issue a ruling on obamacare
and possibly even the outcome of the
presidential election
last night's ceremony was a chance for
mr trump to take a victory lap
i know you will make us all very
very proud one month earlier president
trump announced barrett's nomination
in the rose garden which turned into a
super spreader event
this time guests were socially distanced
on the south lawn
and required to wear a mask but several
hundred still attended
campaigning in pennsylvania former vice
president joe biden said he hoped the
president had learned a lesson from the
first event
i don't blame him for celebrating
there's a lot of things we could be
doing having
massive crowds but the fact is that
it's just not appropriate now while
president trump continues to claim
incorrectly that the virus is under
control vice president pence is taking
extra precautions on the campaign trail
like covering his face at all times
except while on stage
canceling rope lines with supporters and
traveling with a group that is smaller
than usual
he is charging ahead though with a
packed schedule that
includes rallies in six states over the
next
three days tony thank you very much